um
all right denise denise where'd you grow
up where are you from originally i grew
up in kentucky
i was bowling green yeah
and uh how was your childhood you had
both parents growing up
no um
it was i was in foster homes foster home
where what happened to mom and dad
um well like um so my dad was never
i only met him once and then um so
my mom she was like she's always like
chasing around guys
she's been married lots of times and my
sister pretty much is the one who's
always there
for me most of the time how many times
was mom married
i was six six times yeah
[Music]
how would you describe your childhood um
stressful what were the roughest parts
of it
um well like so one of my first memories
is
i was um it was halloween night you know
like when you go back to your when you
first start
made your memories and we were running
through the alley
me and my sister and my mom and her when
her husband at the time was chasing us
with a rifle and we were hiding behind
like this wall thing
and we were trying to be quiet and he
was like where are you guys at
and he was chasing us trying i guess
they were having an argument or whatever
and we were always like having to anger
seriously no he was serious he ran out
of crack
and um so we were always like she was
always running
from her hood like they were always
abusive so we were always like living in
women's shelters and you know like
people are staying with people
and stuff like that and then yeah
and then we moved to kentucky she just
um
he her husband at the time we didn't get
along and
uh he told me i have to i can't live
there
so she i don't know she just like went
along with him and i went in foster
homes
and how did the foster homes treat you
um i i didn't like it i ran away from
every single one
any kind of abuse when you were either
at home or the foster system oh no i
wouldn't call it abuse like i
i did something with one of the foster
ladies brothers
like my foster uncle or whatever yeah
but it wasn't abuse like i
like i didn't you didn't make me you
know right
yeah and how far did you go to school um
which is the
eighth grade and then where'd you go
after that um
just got my ged but did you
go out on your own and try to make a
living or well no like we were still in
kentucky
and then we came out here not expected
to stay out here
but like um so we came out here my
grandma was getting married again
and we were supposed to stay for two
weeks and i guess my mom's seeing her
way out from her husband there
in kentucky so she just left me here and
went flew back and then caught a u-haul
back here with all our stuff
when he was at work so she snuck in
there when he was at work and brought
all her stuff here
and we stayed here and i've been here
ever since and
what you been doing how you've been
surviving prostitution
since since what age i was almost i was
just about to turn 14.
yeah because my grandma we were living
with my grandma
she just got married she didn't really
want us there but my mom like
imposed us you know so
like she mean her didn't really she got
mad because i let i had somebody over it
was like two weeks after we got here
and i didn't really know anybody but i
met this one
girl at um i was a guy as a dude
at um coco's restaurant or whatever and
we exchanged numbers whatever
he came over he was a waiter there and
he came over and i was just bored you
know i didn't know anybody here i didn't
have no friends so
she got mad because he's charging his
cell phone and she embarrassed me she
pushed me down
on the ground and she was like is he
paying for the i said something smart to
her or whatever i got sarcastic
and so then she was like well you can
just get the [ __ ] out no wonder you know
and she just
i had to leave and so like i i didn't
i didn't know anybody and i didn't
really know anything about california
and so this guy just picked me up and um
he was my boyfriend but slash pimp yeah
it's common he pretended to be my
boyfriend for a while yeah that's
that's how they do it now yeah so you've
had more than one pimp or
just um i've been around a lot of pimps
so more than one but i just was with him
mostly yeah
yeah and the arrangement worked for you
or no it didn't work for me
like tell me why not it was just a lot
of work
you know how much money do you end up in
your pocket i couldn't
none the whole time i wouldn't keep
nothing like
like i stayed with him like over four
years and
i got like i would go i would get a room
every day
and mcdonald's or something like that
and a swap meet outfit
and that was about it in a sack of weed
and just have sex with guys all all day
and not me i had two shifts in the
morning i worked the dirty in the sunset
and
in the cleaning of the sunset and at
nighttime i worked down at the bottom
of a figaro no sunset oh sunset
this is a rough life right yeah
it's kind of sucks did you get you
depressed yeah
wait what is that what gets you the most
is it depression or
yeah like i don't want to start crying
just everybody cries here yeah it just
sucks like i wish i could be
somebody else
you know yeah
and drugs are part of the picture for
you too they weren't then but they
became
what drugs are are you using cocaine
crack or cocaine
it's the same thing yeah but once once
when you smoke it when you sniff it but
one stronger than the other think yeah
when you smoke it it's stronger yeah
yeah which one are you using correct
correct
thank you
and today you're you're still doing it
right yeah
on sunset oh no no no i i work the
websites oh you do it too though yeah
is that has that been better for you
it's uh safer
but it's like
stressful too what's what's the roughest
part of it staying on the phone
with a bunch of [ __ ] guys just
wasting time
like i can never put the phone down it's
always like i get like
a bunch of guys will call me okay i'm
coming i'm on the way but then i saw i
just booked all of them i'll be like
okay come right now
maybe one will show up oh really so
they're flaky yeah they're so flake and
another thing all the girls are doing
bareback with everybody and
so when the guys call me they're like
they're all of them like like i say 90
of them are asking for that is with no
condom
all the guys that call because the girls
other girls are out there they're doing
that
type of stuff obviously you know and
then it [ __ ] it up for me
because like i'm i i'm scared to do that
you'd rather not
no i don't care like they'll be like how
much extra and i can't do that
i can't like i feel like paranoid that
like maybe a
prostitute gave it to them and they want
to [ __ ] up all the prostitutes now and
they want to spread it around
you know who knows there's been there's
sick people out there
and now and now it's like i'm struggling
because i can't make no money because of
that they're all
that's what they're all used to you know
so
it's like like now where do i go from
here like i can't survive like this
i have a drug habit and it's just
getting worse as depression goes by
because i'm so broke
you know and then like with my criminal
record like how
it's not like i'm gonna like get a job
to be able to make enough to survive out
here on my own
without doing this do you think there's
a chance of
ever just stopping quitting there's
nothing to do with the drugs like i'm
only doing the drugs because i don't
feel like there's
any reason not to no but but let's say
you know as an outsider watching this as
a square like me
what if you were just to quit the drugs
quit working the street get a job at
wherever
like where groceries nobody will hire me
nobody will hire me why not
my criminal past what what what's on
your record
everything nothing violent
just like um you know embezzlement
commercial burglary you know identity
theft you know drugs prostitution
theft all those type of stuff basically
just points to me bad
yeah and all those arrests were probably
based on drugs
no like i went to prison when i was 18.
before drugs
yeah so the criminal
activity like i have to wait seven more
years before i can expunge it
oh geez yeah you're in a jam then
yeah it's depressing
[Music]
did you have kids i have two kids and
where are they
with their dads do you see them
i see my son once in a while
it's not enough
not because i can't because i'm ashamed
to go there right you know shame is a
big part of all this right
yeah the shame makes it hard to
fix anything and i'm sorry it's okay
i don't know it's gonna be like this
with my kids and stuff can we not talk
about them
sure
so what's the roughest part of this for
you of doing this
living this life myself
the depression and the shame yeah
it's like the past is the roughest part
to me as an outsider you know i i've
seen the life that some of these girls
lead like
nobody is really on your side the other
girls are
competition the prim the pimps are
certainly trying to take advantage
the cops are even trying to even regular
people yeah they don't
like your friends they're not they're
not do you have any friends
i did both of them died so
um one of them something was wrong with
his stomach
and then the other one died in his sleep
do you have any respect for the guys
that pick you up
yeah it depends on how they are
you know depends on they respect me some
of them are cool
some of them are cool yeah
some guys think you know like because
they hand you a little few dollars that
they can talk to you any kind of way or
they can treat you however
or tell you what to do or whatever
and then i go crazy on them
have you ever seen that movie uh monster
oh you've got to see it's a true story
you hear about that girl
that lady she was she became a serious
she was a prostitute she became a serial
killer
it's a true story i feel like um like i
didn't used to have
mental issues like this i've always had
mental issues but
i didn't used to be getting so like
out of control of myself you know
like i'm supposed to be on three
different kinds of meds but i don't like
to take the medicine
so i just try to do it not to control it
if i can
because i'm already on drugs you know so
it's like it's like i
like i wish i was dead sometimes
already have you tried suicide
i've been what
yeah you need to get away from this life
somehow
it's just too destructive a path yeah
some some girls seem to be able to
handle it but you have to be so
cold-hearted and
money-hungry that that's that's all that
works for you
have you ever been alone yeah
how'd that work out i wish i never had
felt it
because he died you know
so and like now
it's like i don't think i'll ever have
it again
probably not yeah and living this life
it makes it
extra difficult right i'm picky yeah
you know it's like i'm not going to find
anybody that
i want to be rich
the girls on the street you think
secretly have this
hope wish that that one of these guys is
going to magically fall in love and
save you and i mean i've had it happen
but i would prefer to be with myself
because it's never it's always something
it's never going to be
the way you want it it's always going to
be
like i'm not going to have nobody save
me nobody can save me
like i can get i can get saved
financially but
like mentally i'm not going to get saved
i'm going to i'm going to find some way
something wrong with the situation to
where i'm uncomfortable i have to be in
control
of everything i think you self-sabotage
yeah yeah definitely like if some prince
charming came along and tried to save
you
no i tried to tell him that i'm saving
him by telling him to get
you don't want me you push him away yeah
because like i'm not good anybody i've
tried to be with they ended up downhill
down just yeah somebody comes to try to
say he died my my
like the one guy that really loved me
ever
like he you know he died i feel like
some of it was my fault because i
stressed about he died how
something was wrong in his under his
ribs or something but
his heart you know when somebody comes
along and tries to save you
it's more likely that you'll take them
down rather than they'll lift you up
i'll try to i'll try to save them first
by telling
them please just you don't want me you
don't want me and then like
but if at the same time like i'll
probably end up needing money from them
and so i call them around or they come
around on their own
and then something i don't know why they
like me i'm crazy i'm
i mean a lunatic i swear when i get mad
you think you're addicted to this life
no no
do you think about it i've lived in
other life too i've lived i was married
you know i didn't i was so i was sober
for like it's almost six years
i did the housewife thing yeah were you
happier then
i was happy with my son yeah i was fun
it was fun
and are you saving money now no no
are you working with a pip now no i'm a
pimp if anything
no i'm just asking yeah i hate pimps
do you have bad experiences they're weak
they're sorry yeah have you have you had
that experience with the guys that pick
you up
oh yeah yeah i've not in a long time but
yeah
everything robbed raped
stabbed you know kidnapped
everything and that's out in hollywood
and hollywood's dangerous
very i think all the neighborhoods are
dangerous yeah they are
but hollywood is like where there was
always something going on
you've been arrested too
is your does your family know you're
doing this
uh yeah
my mom she spreads it all around she
tells everybody
does this like undermine your self-worth
doing this does it undermine your
self-worth this just living this life
or i know i'm worth more i can do better
it's just like the criminal record thing
is kind of in my way
a little bit like i can get a job i can
get a job like in a warehouse with a
bunch of men of course i can get a job
but it's like how's that going to work
out you know they're going to be [ __ ]
like trying to
do stuff or and plus it's not i can't
survive on that anyway who can survive
on minimum wage nobody can do that
especially
here i mean i'd be having a wet [ __ ]
we're in a room from somebody
what the same thing so you started this
at 14.
do you remember do you recall your very
first time doing it yeah
tell me about that it was just um i was
on
pacific coast highway and i jumped in
this mexican's van
and did the date in the van
and what was your reaction afterwards
you got you got good money for it
i was like hell yeah i was excited at
first
it's tempting to continue right yeah
what was the best time in your life when
i had my son
when i was with him what's been the
worst time
there's been a lot of worse times i
can't pick which one
it sounds like you've been through a lot
but it could be worse you know yeah it's
always to me like somebody
i don't mean to sound like like happy at
somebody else's
like misery but there's always somebody
that's got it ten times worse than when
you feel down like that
you have to remember that it could get
it always it's not it's not that bad
how do you think living this life has
changed you you've been doing it for a
while now
it's changed me as far as my mental
health
like i i'm a [ __ ] to everybody like i
don't want to be around
people i hide from people i isolate
myself
i'm embarrassed you know
all i think about is tomorrow
you ever you ever just stand back and
look at what you're doing and go man
this is
yeah such a rough life yeah like what
can i like i can go to a shelter i can
go to a church or something like that
but it's like now my cocaine habit is so
much that like if i was not not get high
say like tonight i didn't get high i
would be in a coma like
stuck asleep for probably like a week or
two and i don't have enough money to pay
my rent for that
long time if i want to stop using i'm
not going to be able to like do anything
i'm not going to be able to work
because i breathe i breathe crack you
know
so just to get it off of the crack
is and to be able to pay my rent would
be
stressful
what advice would you give to somebody
who's considering this
line of work like
you only get one life
and be grateful for the life
that you have before any of this bad
stuff comes
because once it comes your life is like
once the damage is done is done
not even like just with yourself
a waste of time like you like i'm mad at
myself
you know mostly i can't be mad at nobody
else
[Music]
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
[Music]
don't trust anybody nobody
always expect the worst and hope for the
best
all right are we done yes made it short
right
it was 21 minutes not bad yeah
not too bad you did great thanks is it
still filming
it is okay denise thank you very much
thank you that was easy it was easy
painless
you feel a little better yeah yeah
i don't want to go out there with my
does my makeup all messed up no you look
great
let me give you some money and make you
smile and make your day a little easier
it's the easiest money you've made
all year probably right no
you probably have one twisted guy that
gives you like 400 bucks for doing
nothing
yeah but he's creepy yes
you ask me some deep questions